[Music]
on this Friday night ottawa's
multi-billion Dollar Bet on electric
Volkswagen lands one of the biggest
Federal subsidies in Canadian history
this is an enormous amount of money what
it means for the sector in the Ontario
Town bracing for generational change the
scale of this is so big immigration
implications hundreds of thousands
desperate to call Canada home left in
limbo as a historic Federal strike drags
on each day will cost a lot to our
country a golden Heist questions Swirl
at Canada's largest airport over
millions in missing gold was it an
inside job and saving Irreplaceable
Giants our future Generations depend on
those things the new form of Engagement
taking route and fight for Canada's
global national with para Nasser
good evening thank you for joining us
the world's biggest car company
Volkswagen says it will build its first
manufacturing facility in Canada near
the city of Saint Thomas in Southwestern
Ontario the automaker says it will spend
7 billion dollars to build a huge
battery plant for electric vehicles it
will employ 3 000 people and create
thirty thousand spin-off jobs the
federal government is also promising
Volkswagen billions in subsidies but for
all the promised benefits there's no
getting around taxpayers putting up a
significant chunk of money in our top
story tonight our chief political
correspondent David Aiken examines the
question is it worth it
Volkswagen welcome to Ontario
Ontario's Premier was all smiles and why
not a huge investment that will create
thousands of new jobs not just in the
Southwestern Ontario Town of Saint
Thomas but in other communities up and
down Ontario's Highway 401 Corridor and
it's an investment backstop by one of
the biggest Federal subsidies ever given
to a private company potentially more
than 13 billion dollars the Prime
Minister said that is money well spent
let's be really clear about what's
happening here today
other parts of the world including our
neighbors to the South
were willing to put up an awful lot of
money
to get this project there
what Trudeau was talking about is Joe
Biden's Landmark industrial policy the
inflation reduction act its legislation
which promises 500 billion dollars in
subsidies to companies who build Green
Technology plants in the U.S Canada's
government and many in Europe have been
worried Biden's generous subsidies means
they'll lose out on these so-called
factories of the future so yes we put up
a lot of money money that's going to
come back in investments in economic
activity very quickly we've got to be
smart and we've got to compete and we
can land a few of these and we should go
for it I don't know if there's a bigger
win than the biggest car company in the
world deciding to do their most
expensive Advanced products and putting
them in the hands of Canadian workers
some Wonder though if this battery
Factory as big as it is comes at too
high a cost for the federal treasury the
r d for these batteries will likely take
place somewhere else Germany most likely
and the Assembly of the electric
vehicles using these batteries will also
occur somewhere else likely in the U.S
this is an enormous amount of money for
a very narrow part of the autoin of the
Auto industry is an important part but
it's a very narrow part but the Prime
Minister argues this facility will be a
national anchor that will put Canada at
the heart of the 21st century supply
chain for new kinds of cars and trucks
and he says Canada would miss that
opportunity without the financial
contribution of its taxpayers Para
thanks David that's David Aiken
reporting from Ottawa
the province of Ontario has been pushing
to be a hub for electric vehicle
manufacturing for some time and as David
mentioned this is a big boost for a
small city as Mike droulet reports from
St Thomas There's Hope of benefits for
generations to come
St Thomas may be a small City but big
news it's used to that this is after all
where the legendary jumbo the elephant
tragically died in 1885.
today it's a city that's showing a
desperate need for economic
revitalization that believes it's now
set itself up for generational success
I've really found it's tough to go to
sleep at night when you're smiling what
VW is bringing to the area is huge
literally and figuratively the
gigafactory will be roughly one
kilometer long by 1.5 kilometers wide or
600 city blocks so if is it a success of
15 years from now you look at St Thomas
and you still recognizing yeah I think
so look and and
young people used to have to go away to
University and never come back are now
staying because we've created a a
community where where you can grow up
with your children where you can have a
job that you can buy a house working at
it all seems so perfect three thousand
direct jobs and another thirty thousand
will be needed across the province to
help support the factory but St Thomas
is a city of forty five thousand and
there aren't enough qualified people in
The Province to fill the need for
skilled trades now we had 440
000 immigrants come to Ontario just last
year alone we're going to have a
continual flow but yet you have to train
them though we have a part of our plan
with Volkswagen is training through
Fanshawe College if all that works out
there's still the question of
infrastructure Millions will be spent
upgrading the highways and services and
the city's Economic Development leads
are already planning new subdivisions
they've given assurances to VW that they
can get it done the scale of this is so
big that certainly the Gateway of the
community when you're coming in from
London it's not going to look the same
you know I'm a little concerned people
are going to say oh St Thomas is that
town next to the battery plan you know
we're using that instead of the other
way around but that's maybe not such a
bad thing to be known for and
sustainability is something we all care
about here in St Thomas and this is a
great step towards that for our country
if everything falls into place this will
be a transformative deal for the city
not only for decades but they hope
lifetimes microlight Global News St
Thomas Ontario
and on the immigration file a strike by
federal public workers is plunging
hundreds of thousands of immigration
applications into uncertainty new
applications are no longer being
processed Korea Israel spoke to some of
the newcomers who are now stuck in limbo
Larry Nanda is getting ready to start
her career and make Canada her permanent
home the international student from
India just graduated from Carleton
University in Ottawa but in order to
land a full-time job Nanda needs a work
permit if I don't get that in time
combined with the strike there is a risk
for me having to go back to India tens
of thousands of federal public workers
have walked off the job
that includes the civil servants who
handle immigration files clients should
expect to experience serious delays with
processing applications across all of
our immigration streams Yasmine izazi is
already experiencing delays so raise
your right hand and so join in she
passed her citizenship test but is now
stalled at the very last step it's
something that you take pride in you
know becoming a Canadian Citizen and um
just going to that ceremony now her
ceremony will likely be pushed back
especially as an Iranian it's more
difficult for me to travel with my
current passport at any given time
around a million applications are making
their way through Canada's immigration
system and right now many of them are on
pause because of the strike immigration
lawyers warn this will have a profoundly
negative impact on students families and
the economy
the Canadian government is relying
heavily on immigration to deal with a
severe labor shortage each day will cost
a lot to our country to our economy to
our universities to our tourism every
industry sector is going to be affected
by this
Nanda is hoping for a quick resolution I
want to see employees be satisfied with
what they're asking for
but I also want to see International
students being cared for a little more a
little more consideration being given to
us we're trying to you know strive for a
better lifestyle here in Canada the
dream of a better life that's just
become more complicated Korea isri
Global News Ottawa
a Paris court has convicted a Lebanese
Canadian academic In Absentia on
terrorism charges
hacindia was sentenced to life in prison
over a bombing outside of Paris
synagogue in 1980 that killed four and
wounded 46. the court issued an arrest
warrant for the now 69 year old who
lives in Ottawa and denies any
wrongdoing diab spent three years behind
bars in France before judges dismissed
the allegations against him in 2018 but
in 2021 France's Top Court rejected an
appeal and ordered him to stand trial
supporters are now calling on Canada to
refuse any new extradition request from
France
former liberal MP Han dong who now sits
as an independent has filed a defamation
suit against Global News and our parent
company chorus entertainment in a
statement of claim that was filed on
Thursday dunk says he was portrayed as a
traitor and knowing participant in
Chinese interference in Canada
the suit is related to global news
reporting that two independent National
Security sources said dong had a
conversation in 2021 with the Chinese
Consul General in which dong raised the
cases of Michael kovrick and Michael
spever in allegedly advised China to
delay their release dong denies the
allegations and calls the stories
malicious irresponsible and defamatory
he's seeking a retraction of the stories
and broadcasts allegations in the
statement of claim have not been tested
in court
near Toronto investigators are trying to
wrap their head around an audacious
Heist straight out of Netflix police say
a container is storing 20 million
dollars worth of valuable items
including gold was somehow stolen off a
plane at Pearson International Airport
now where the loot is who the culprits
are and even how they pull this off is
still a mystery and the crime is Raising
big questions about the state of
security at Canada's largest airport
arshan O'Shea has more tonight Sean
before you see gold heists in movies all
the time but this one was real and it
was worth 20 million dollars
Canada's biggest airport beyond the
passenger terminals where the movement
of people and cargo is key but this week
thieves were able to get their hands on
one shipping container that stood out
inside gold and other valuables the
total worth estimated at this time in
our investigation for the property is
estimated at just over 20 million
dollars a police Source tells Global
News Air Canada cargo was handling the
gold and other valuables in a statement
Air Canada says it has no information to
provide on the situation the 20 million
in gold and valuables hasn't been seen
since somebody messed up here for uh the
security on this veteran former Toronto
police officer Craig burmell says the
case raises broader concerns about
safety at the airport my first thought
was if it was this easy to get out with
a product how easy is to get in with a
product and you can let your imagination
go on that one some who heard about the
theft agree supposed to be secure for
families and people are supposed to feel
safe and I guess that would make anybody
feel safe right doesn't make you feel
safe no not at all no I'm very surprised
it's like unsafe for all of us in this
case our first thing I think is inside
job obviously like how do you know that
that's there experts say that's a safe
assumption somebody obviously knew that
it was going to be coming and somebody
knew that it was there security broke
down often what companies have is
somewhat dependent on what kind of cargo
they ship and often that's driven by the
requirements of their insurance company
police won't say who owned the property
or what else was inside the container
along with the gold
no one was hurt in the heist and police
say Public Safety was not at risk
experts say though if it was this easy
to steal 20 million dollars what else is
possible pharah Sean O'Shea thank you
breaking news from the U.S the Supreme
Court is protecting access to a widely
used abortion drug nifipristone will
remain available for now halting a
decision by the lower court that would
have restricted access to the commonly
used pill the lower court was attempting
to roll back FDA approval of the drug it
has been approved for two decades this
is a victory for the Biden
Administration as it fights to protect
women's reproductive rights in post Roe
v Wade America
Friendly Fire caught on tape coming up
panic after a Russian war plane Dropped
a Bomb on one of its own cities
[Music]
Russia is admitting one of its warplanes
accidentally Dropped a Bomb on a City
close to the border with Ukraine causing
a huge explosion three people were
injured in the blast that left a crater
20 meters deep the explosion was so
strong it sent a car flying onto a store
roof several buildings were also damaged
Canada is sending another 39 million
dollars to Ukraine in military aid
defense minister Anita Anand made the
announcement today from Germany during a
meeting with NATO allies the donation
includes almost 35 million dollars to
help Ukraine buy fuel first aid kits and
other non-lethal Provisions through a
special fund set up by NATO the rest of
the money is for sniper rifles
ammunition and new radio sets for the
eight leopard two tanks Canada donated
to Ukraine
a photograph taken last March in Ukraine
has won the World Press photo of the
Year award
the harrowing image shows a pregnant
woman being carried through the
shattered remains of a maternity
hospital in maryupal that 32 year old
died just after giving birth to the
lifeless body of her baby it's being
called one of the most defining images
of Russia's war in Ukraine we'll be
right back
random acts of violence are on the rise
across Canada on public transit on city
streets and they're even happening in
places meant for peace and quiet as
Melissa original reports cases of verbal
and physical violence are in our public
libraries and they're increasing as well
he was a gem he was that guy that never
left anybody out Tanya Kai's son Tyree
was a regular visitor at Winnipeg's
Millennium library in December he was at
the library when the 28 year old was
stabbed they showed up at my door at
five in the morning
to tell me that my son had been murdered
four teenagers have been charged in his
death incidents of violence are
happening in libraries right across the
country I did have one year where every
three months I was assaulted Cameron Ray
and Ayla mcleish worked as supervisor
Librarians at the Toronto Reference
Library this guy chased me around the
branch with a pair of hair scissors I've
come across overdose victims people who
are unconscious a library reflects the
larger world around it Siobhan Stevenson
has studied the changing role of public
libraries people are coming to the
library and they have really significant
needs there's all kinds of social crises
you know homelessness opioid epidemic
random acts of violence in places like
just a social safety net that's been so
diminished with cuts to Social Services
many people with complex problems have
nowhere to turn most of the time it is
someone who has been chewed up and spit
out by society and they're at the end of
their rope libraries are one of the few
spaces with doors open to everyone our
whole reason for existing is to be open
to everyone without judgment but at the
same time of being welcoming we also
need to be a safe environment for our
staff and for our customers the Edmonton
Public Library recognized its vulnerable
clients needed more services hey it
became one of the first in Canada to
bring in social workers a library is a
great place for a social worker because
it's barrier-free and accessible
after tyree's death the Millennium
Library installed a metal detector and
added a regular police presence
tyree's mother doesn't blame the library
she says the problem is much bigger
Winnipeg is struggling with youth crime
it's struggling with drugs it there
there's a million and one issues this is
just one of them libraries point out
it's only a tiny fraction of the visits
that ever turn violent nationally
they're working together to find
solutions to keep libraries safe and
that means continuously evolving to meet
the needs of the community pharah
Melissa Richard and Winnipeg thanks
Melissa and Melissa we'll have more on
how libraries are meeting these
challenges as the public spaces
transform watch the new reality Saturday
at 7 right here on global
[Music]
lost out from Jurassic Park next the
coach who helped Toronto get its first
NBA championship gets the boot
the Raptors haven't won any hardware
since then and after another Bad season
finishing ninth the Raptors fired head
coach Nick nurse today Vice chairman and
president Messiah jury says changing the
culture and reigniting the Rapture
spirit is at the heart of this decision
the feel the spirit of who we really are
it's
it's been very disappointing for us and
we want to gain our momentum back
Jerry says there is nothing contentious
about the firing that it's simply about
winning in the future and he thanked
Nick nurse for his service
it's easy to forget the benefits of
trees in our environment and to our
health and their deep histories they can
span far longer than our lifetimes Nito
Garcia reports on a registry created by
researchers in British Columbia that's
ensuring The Towering Giants get the
attention and the protection that they
deserve
forests in BC are a treasure Trove of
biodiversity and natural beauty
but there's so much more to these Lush
lands than meets the eye think about
just how interconnected we are as humans
with forests Ira Sutherland is a
researcher focused on the benefits of
forests I'm breathing in the oxygen
provided by this tree and I'm exhaling
carbon dioxide that's taken in by this
tree to produce energy and sugar the
structure of the forest Sutherland says
one way to understand the importance of
forests is through the big tree registry
a Community Driven initiative to record
some of the province's biggest trees so
why do you actually map the location of
these big trees
well that spatial information is really
important for informing how we can plan
uh to conserve those trees anyone can
nominate any tree and share a story
about why it's special in this case
Sutherland is meeting one of those tree
enthusiasts hey good to finally meet you
nice to meet you yeah for fun for
something to do really honestly and you
know and it's turned into a lot more
it's it's more about conservation for me
now all right got that there which is
why Michael Warner is eager to equip
himself with new knowledge about
identifying and measuring trees we're
co-evolving together changes in society
are co-evolving with changes in forests
it's something those like Elder and
canoe Carver Joe Martin who worked with
Sutherland on this film promoting
sustainable Forest management has long
known our future Generations depend on
those things Martin told us indigenous
oral teachings passed down for
Generations about always leaving the
land in a better condition Mission than
it's found is something he hopes more
people will reflect on people should
follow and see indigenous people's
teachings across the world wherever they
come from is this like a natural part of
it Sutherland hopes his research
initiatives will help more people
recognize their more than awe-inspiring
natural wonders to be admired but living
organisms essential to the health of our
planet
Global News Vancouver
and that's global national for this
Friday I'm Farah Nasser thanks for being
with us and for those of you celebrating
Eid Mubarak we leave you with Eid
celebrations across Canada on one of the
biggest events in the Islamic calendar
from coast to coast to coast people
gathered for prayers and to celebrate
Eve the end of the Muslim holy month of
Ramadan until tomorrow take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good night
[Music]